damon lindelof joins us now i of course
i told you guys i always book with my
friend so i feel comfortable when i come
out and do the show and damon's gonna
come on right now hi damon are you there
hi i'm here can you hear me i can hear
you beautifully thank you for joining us
today to br
i know cause wouldn't it be awful if it
was like static it's like
it's a new thing that we say in the
pandemic can you hear me am i muted
am i it's it's a thing so it's so nice
to
hear your voice well thank you very much
i do appreciate that we wanted you to
come on or i wanted you to come
on to be my handicapper for the golden
globes
obviously because you know something
about writing the greatest television in
the world both in lost and the leftovers
watchmen but
before we talk tv walk me through your
childhood as a yankees fan
i was born in new jersey um in northern
new jersey just over the george
washington bridge so both my folks
worked in manhattan my mom was a
public school teacher in harlem and my
dad worked for citibank and as neutra as
you're aware new jersey does not have a
professional
um baseball team we have the new jersey
devils but uh
but that's about it and so you have to
choose whether you're a mets fan or a
yankees fan
my father did not know anything about
sports or
care about sports i don't think he
literally
knew that there were nine innings in a
baseball game
and my mom realized that this would be a
deficit for
a young boy growing up um in in the
world and so
she curated sports for me and brought me
to
games and the first game that she
brought me to was a yankees game so
i i became enamored of the of the
yankees in the late 70s which was a very
exciting time to be a yankees fan
and mostly you know my my gateway
um into the yankees was reggie jackson
so uh
um i was just immensely
enamored with with mr october and
um and so that was the beginning of uh
what has become a 47 year
love affair with the uh with the new
york yankees
and uh i love the dodgers too i moved
out to la
and um in the early 90s and obviously
they have brooklyn roots but if and when
the yankees play the dodgers i
i find myself rooting for the yankees so
that's
uh that's that's the long and short of
it what's your idea of
of a perfect sports movie or a perfect
sports show
oh man well friday night lights is the
gold standard i actually have
um my fandom for that show is
um is off the charts and uh
and i talked about it obsessively over
the course of the last decade and so
their
um their art department actually heard
me blathering on and on about how
much i loved it so i have a clear heart
a full eyes clear heart can't lose uh
you know the replica over my over the
door to my office and i tap it
whenever i come in in the morning so i
think that's the
that's the quintessential sports tv show
for me
and i think like the natural is probably
my favorite
um uh sports movie although
you know there i have a there's a
special place in my heart for
hoosiers as well um those are like both
movies that were kind of
running over and over again on on hbo in
the early days before
you know vcrs had proliferated and you
would watch a movie
85 times so i i know both of those
movies
pretty much chapter and verse emmy
award-winning writer
and producer damon lindelof from lost
leftovers watchmen joins us now on the
rich eisen show i'm susie shuster in for
rich
you and i joked around about tom brady
in his preparation for the super bowl
what struck you as most interesting
about the way he got ready
look i mean i i'm i'm a
i'm a jets fan as well so the
um from the moment that bill parcells
left to go
to new england i hated the patriots and
so
this is nothing against tom brady
personally because he was a patriot for
so long
um and i i can acknowledge that he is an
incredible football player if not the
goat but
um but i do i do feel there's a part of
me as a father
that you shouldn't be able to send your
children away
um as an excuse for excellence in any
field
and so when i heard that he sent his
kids packing
um this this latest uh for this latest
super bowl
so that he could kind of get in the of
the appropriate headspace to win the
game
i was like do you know what happened to
me if i said to my wife
we need to send our son away for a
couple of weeks because
i'm writing this episode of television
and it's really important because it's a
finale
like i i just i i kind of feel like
if you have to send your kids away
you're not really that great you know
like how distracting your kids
just just tell them to keep it down a
little i guess well knowing your wife i
don't think that would be a very
successful conversation but that's
neither here nor there
there's something i love to say all the
time oh all love for heidi and by the
way i don't want to be married to
someone who lets me send my children
away
um so that i so that i can excel
which is an excellent point of that
watchmen a lot of people are wondering
why you're done
was there any thought in your mind to
come back
no i mean i i love watchmen i have loved
it since the mid 80s when it first came
out as a comic book and
i think that like there's now an entire
generation of filmmakers and
storytellers who were fans of the
original and now
we kind of get to do our spin on it and
i'm a huge comic book
nerd so there's a leg you know there's a
legacy and an expectation in comic books
that a writer
comes in and does what's called a run
and
like on a on a character so you know
someone comes in and does
batman for a year or two and then they
move on and so on and so forth
and alan moore who is the writer um and
dave gibbons who is the artist of
watchmen
um they both did incredible runs on a
number of
iconic characters swamp thing batman
green lantern
superman uh etc and then they left and
then other writers came in and so
i made it pretty clear from the jump
that i was you know
that me and the my creative partners the
incredible writers and
directors and storytellers on watchmen
that we were just going to put it all
into this one season you know like
uh to use the sports metaphor it's sort
of like we're going all the way we're
going to leave everything on the field
we're not going to save anything for
later this is not a team building
scenario where like let's just let's
just let's just go out and try to win
every single game and play
um play our best ball and and we we did
we by the end of that we were exhausted
but i do feel like we crafted a season
that had a beginning middle and
end and i've been you know um pretty
consistent in saying
now watchmen now the doors of the
factory are open anybody who wants to
come in
i'll show them around and say here's how
the machinery works
but i but i'm i i kind of i think would
be more exciting if people came in and
said like i don't want to make it in
this factory i'm kind of building my own
so my hope is that we'll all get to see
more watchmen
you know that it doesn't take 30 years
to see more watchmen but
i i don't think it should be made by me
but it wouldn't could it go on with
regina but not with you
oh absolutely i mean you know why not
like uh that that that's kind of up to
regina but i
but i do think like you know look at the
marvel movies you know john
favreau directed iron man um which was
sort of like the pilot
for all of those great marvel movies but
by time you get to
avengers infinity war and uh end game
now the russo brothers are directing it
and and inside of there you have ryan
coogler directing
you know in my opinion probably the best
uh marvel movie black panther and so
he has creative stewardship over that
character but you know it's it
um like this is the way that comic book
storytelling works is you know those
actors
are going to get to work with a bunch of
different writers and directors
and they it's their responsibility to
maintain the sort of
you know continuity integrity of the
character as
as they move forward so you know chris
nolan made
a number of great batman movies but he's
not the only one who can make batman
movies and if christian bale wants to
make
a batman movie with another filmmaker he
should be able to
dave and lindelof here on the rich eisen
show damon what's next for you
well i am uh i'm working on a couple of
different
um tv projects at a slightly higher
altitude than i'm used to
and by that i mean i'm i'm more
interested in in
performing creative partnerships with uh
younger storytellers
who haven't really had their chance to
pilot the ship themselves
um i i i got my first crack at
running a show when i was 30 years old
and jj
abrams gave me that opportunity and i
kind of feel like
i it's my turn to return the favor and i
also feel like
the older i get the more obstinate i get
or set in my ways and the best way to
shake
shake myself out of that that that
ridiculous notion that i know what i'm
doing
is to um is to sort of learn from uh
from younger artists who are coming up
in the world so hopefully
um i haven't been as productive during
the pandemic as
as some of my peers have or i wish that
i had
been but um you know uh i've got a
couple of
things that are moving from the back
burner to the front burner hopefully
we'll be able to announce
some some point in the late spring early
summer i love how nonchalantly you say
oh i ran a show it was lost
it was amazing it's epic it's the source
of non-stop conversation yesterday
vulture came out in new york magazine
the vulture article about
lost and people still get so angry
about the ending does that still
surprise you how passionate people are
about the ending of lost you know
it's actually really it in the in the
short term
obviously i had the you know the hubris
to think that i could write something
that everyone would love
um and over time i've i've come to learn
that that
was impossible but more importantly like
the fact that anyone is still talking
about it
you know the finale aired in 2010 and so
that the finale aired 11 years ago and
the show
started in 2004 so 16 17 years ago
the fact that anybody's talking about it
at all is immensely gratifying to me
no matter what they have to say and one
of the things that i understand
you know to circle back to sports is
like is what it means to be a fan
and so i as a jets fan i'm allowed to
talk
incessantly about how much the jets how
terrible they are and how badly they
suck
and all the wrong decisions they're
making but i love the jets
and um and i think that that's a part of
fandom too
and so the idea that people didn't like
the finale but they still loved lost
um or they think like that i'm a hack
but they still watched 120 hours of the
show
i actually do take um like that that
that warms my heart as opposed to chills
it um
i i have a much different perspective on
fandom in general than i did
at the time that lost ended and
considering there's so much
incredible tv out there not just that's
on right now but that has been made over
the course of the last
you know 30 40 years the golden age of
television or the new golden age of
television
the fact that lost is in the
conversation that it's remembered
as opposed to faded away i think that's
pretty cool
speaking of golden what is your take on
the golden globes there on nbc this
sunday at eight eastern time
what has been your favorite watch this
year what are you looking at
and both uh we have a minute and a half
left so we'll say both in
maybe should we say like drama and
comedy unless there's an actor actress
that you love
first off i just have to say that was
like an a-list segue that you just did
speaking of golden pivoting the golden
globes i mean rich could never do that
that was good right i'm not going to lie
done
i'm not going to lie dawn's in my ear
and he threw that out so i'm going to
give him credit because it was good all
right
a a a list segway very nice
golden globes i mean like how much
energy should we put into this because
it's not the oscars it's not it's not a
jury of our peers the globes are
are are coming to task for not having
any members
any black members in the hfpa hopefully
they're going to change that so that
needs to be said um but i think that
like
in the in the in the movie category for
drama
it's um it's a duel between trial the
chicago 7 and nomad land
i i personally thought nomad land was an
incredibly beautiful movie
uh my wife and i loved it so i think
it's the best uh
movie of the year um but i think it's
gonna
trial chicago seven wins it probably
takes it away
and in the comedy category it's borat
versus hamilton
very strange um duel there hamilton
obviously
just a filmed uh version of the
incredible stage play
so i can't imagine that borat is going
to win a golden globe i but i want to
see sasha baron cohen's speech
so i'm kind of rooting for it but
hamilton's still an incredible show
and then um in the uh in the actor
category i'd love to see chadwick
boseman
um obviously tragically lost his life
this last year
um uh i'd love him to win for ma
rainey's uh black bottom
uh and uh and uh the aforementioned
uh nomad land chloe zhao was the
director of that movie i'd love to see
her win
for director again it's just like it's
an incredible beautiful
uplifting movie about america and the
people who get left behind
but it's not a downer and couldn't
recommend it more highly
golden globes sunday night nbc 8 eastern
time damon thank you for your time
thanks for stopping by the rich eisen
show
always a pleasure have a great weekend
thank you you too
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here